you wanted to see me sir  sound girl thank you coach i prefer to  stand  all right go ahead then  tell me  tell you what  why a team worth 800 million dollars one  of the most complex offenses ever built  should put you in the driver's seat  you're too old to be working too green  to be a pro  so why in the world would i give you  this shot  [Music]  all my life  i've defined myself through sports  i've always come up empty  coach i can win for you you need to  start thinking about life after football  son  we gave you the chance  we're letting you go  [Music]  i was meant for something  something more  you think you could be that guy  yeah i do  what are you doing here  i wasn't ready for it  but i am now  you define all nonsense  [Music]  if you give me a chance green went down  hard and is not getting up  i will not let you down  [Music]  you want to prove that  [Music]  [Music]  you